did you guys hear what came up with the
santis yesterday no did you see the
article with bloomberg i just sent it to
you pull it up i emailed it to you so
this article came out yesterday from
bloomberg talking about
who is supporting desantis for 2022
potentially 2024 him against trump 2024.
obviously he talked yesterday that he's
running again for you know 2022 governor
governor but watch this so wall street
publicly they're finally making it
obvious who they're supporting for 2024
if a republican ran pull up the article
kai i just sent you a bloomberg article
um
take a look at this so
this is
wall street helps ron desantis a massive
hefty war chest for 2022 wall street
okay
florida's governor has raked in millions
from donors like ken griffin and thomas
peter peter fi who calls desantis his
favorite
man three years old when it comes to
like the republican president canada
antonio and four wall street journal
this santa's non-former donald trump
who's been teasing another run at the
white house a fifth of the 55 million
dollars that the census has raised this
year came from hedge fund billionaires
private equity bankers investment
managers or other finance industry
donors trump who got less than two
percent of his 2020 re-election fund
from wall street has raised a bulk of
100 million dollar war chest from small
donors now go a little lower check this
out this is the breakdown
uh black desantis blue uh trump uh uh
donors
18.6 percent
from securities and investment industry
versus 1.9 10 by
did you see this or no this is not
saying okay
so republican republican conservatives
12.6 versus 3.6 real estate real estate
his industry three times nine three two
three two but retired republican 24-2
desantis uh uh trump 24-2 the census a2
lawyers and law firms nearly four times
2.5 okay i'm sorry but here's a check
here so this this ought to tell you a
lot about this what does this tell you
exactly tells you a lot tells you that
even yes republic even wall street is
okay with descendants being the
president but they would much rather
have him over trump and how many of his
ideas are ideas are totally different
from trump's not much but do you
remember the question
wait wait wait wait wait wait no i i
have a trick question i have one more
question for adam oh let's hear it okay
oh who sure i won't get it right oh my
gosh don't do it your challenge is too
early in the morning don't hurt my ego
here who donated to both of kamala
harris's campaigns who donated to both
of hillary clinton's campaigns and who
signed paying people to not work into
law
donald j trump thank you
much have you noticed that republican
conservatives and people and securities
they he's the one who signed the damn
bill he's the one who how much that the
not working because he's a new york
democrat which they get the guys in new
york who are in palm beach now whatever
they understand they they know who he is
and remains which is a new york democrat
you're talking about they're not plugged
into newsmax 24 7 like the retirees they
think for themselves i think there's a
typo here i honestly think it's a typo
data florida division of election and
center for responsive politics i think
that's supposed to be responsible
oh i don't know
pointing out the small prince way to go
but going back no longer responsible
going back
here's where i go with this interesting
this is why i asked rogan i said rokin
go to 2024 go to 2022 when republicans
start running for presidency okay
who's going to be on that stage i said
is trump going to be on that stage he
said yes is the center is going to be on
that stage yes i said is pence is going
to be on that stage she says i don't
think so he said he didn't think so
right now hence then we talked about
what nikki haley haley he's right okay
tucker and i said
tucker right but tucker was fifth one
percent tucker okay i don't see because
he's got a good life why would you do it
so you go through a lot of these guys
that you look at okay
my a lot of people are saying a trump
desantis ticket trump desantis ticket
right trump desantis ticket
i don't
think the santis does it
i it's not that the republicans may not
like that or you know that may not work
yeah that's sitting on desantis mirror
right now
he he printed out the chart and it's
sitting on his mirror right now when
he's shaving he's looking at him here's
what my concern is here's what my
concern is here's what my concern is you
ready here's my biggest concern
my biggest concern is that 2022 2023
remember when i said this this is a big
concern of mine my concern is when these
guys are on stage
and trump starts let's just say desantis
takes the lead and those polls come out
and trump goes to try to destroy
desantis
the party starts going at it against
each other
there could be a lot of conflict there
if that takes place i don't see
trump saying yes the sentence is the
face you go ahead and do it i can't see
that happening okay okay okay not even
close but in order for your scenario to
play out don't you think that the
democrats would have to retain the
senate and and congress in 2022 i mean
if there's a bloodbath in 2022 in the
midterm elections yeah and
which is normal and the conservative
which is very normal and because they're
pissed off about this right now
it's it's poised to be that but it's
supposed to be if you look in history
it's practically it's place
i mean pelosi's got what three three
three seats in congress swing factor for
her votes and you just need one in the
senate one i don't know if people are
tired of listening to pelosi i think
people want a little bit more of pelosi
it's very pleasant
help us all all i'm saying thank you
patrick thank you
your scenario does not necessarily have
to play out if 2022 is a bloodbath and
republicans start to push back
and legislate for the people and work
with joe manchin and cross the aisle and
be more like clinton and be more so
where are you going
i'm saying that there is a shot there's
a shot in hell that if the midterms are
bloody enough
that the republicans take congress back
that there are enough moderates emerging
in the democratic party that we might
actually be able to legislate in america
again which we haven't done for a long
time you bring up a really good point
and if you if you know your history and
if you don't i'll share something
what happens with 2024 though what does
that have to do with 2024 with desantis
and trump it has to do with uniting the
country
and and people saying i don't want
somebody who wants to divide us now that
i've started to see what united can look
like
our congress is actually working for we
the people finally finally for the first
time in a millennial's lifetime there
might be a functional congress are you
saying we won't want like the american
people are not going to want to trump as
a candidate is that what you're saying
the american people if if they start to
really because joe biden said he was
going to unite the country he's torn it
further apart than it was before
americans if you're offspring if if
there is a if there is a means by which
to truly unite this country
if there is then then americans will not
vote for somebody who they know is going
to divide it that's all i'm saying
you're saying that that's what trump
would do is that what you're saying
that's that that is that is and has been
his strategy
i don't i mean d does a tiger stripe
change not when he's 78 years old
oh yeah and by the way look again i
think we need a young inspiring
dynamic
energetic
out out of the box thinker in the white
house
not somebody that you're worried is
going to keel over or can't even do you
know
an interview with george stephanopoulos
or or corrects a cnn reporter that's not
the question you're supposed to be
asking me you were supposed to ask me
this question and therefore this is my
answer i'm like
i'm like did the united states president
really just correct a cnn reporter
because his press conferences or staged
events let me ask you this when remember
when hillary was going against the
sanders
remember hillary sanders i'm talking
2015 right hillary centers are going
back and forth
do you really think at the end sanders
when he asked his people to support
hillary do you think they did like do
you think they actually went and
supported hillary
um do you think they did no no no i
don't know okay statistically they just
got quiet that's what i'm saying
so so guys here's where i'm going so go
to a situation do you think republicans
in georgia voted for republican senators
or do you think that they listen to
trump who said if you don't give me
those 11 983 votes i'm going to tell my
people to vote negative on tape that's a
quote
yeah so so again this is where i'm going
with this though my question is so go
there and desantis is the lead okay
you do you see trump going out there and
to asking mega to support desantis
i don't know if i see that but i do know
that he understands numbers oh no i get
he understood of course he he wouldn't
be a billionaire if he didn't understand
numbers here's well i i think it's
questionable that he's a billionaire but
that's a different discussion for a
different day listen let's just say he
is or he's not you fly a 757 with 767
for 30 years
he gasses 12 grand a freaking hour i
mean that argument has been done with so
he's rich let's we're not going to argue
the rich part yeah so but but going back
to going back to that
do you foresee him getting up there and
saying hey you know look uh i conceded i
talked to desantis he's the right
candidate and i'm asking mega we got to
help this man get elected because it's
about taking biden out do you think
trump does this he's sincere
remember he was caught on tape saying if
you give me if you break the law and
fraudulently give me votes in georgia i
will make sure that my people elect
those two senators and mitch mcconnell
will not lose the majority position are
you saying he won't do that i'm saying
if he's sincere about it his people will
follow that's not the question i would
no why would donald trump if he's give
two shits about ron desantis think about
it
rhonda sanders i'm asking you guys i'm
not i don't have the answer
two shits about ron desantis other than
the fact that ronnie sanders has become
a superstar since florida has become the
new haven of america other than texas
because
was a nobody under trump okay so he
didn't like he's a mini trump and he
shot up but that's my favorite he showed
up to stardom
shit's about to santa's name is
different it was his vp let me give a
different analogy let me give a
different name yeah okay so
uh uh
magic johnson is the face of the league
show michael jordan shows up magic's got
five championships michael's got zero
1992 dream team michael's got one
magic's got five
magic larry tells mike magic after he
kicks their ass he says what it's no
longer our league it's his league okay
i felt like i saw jesus playing
basketball and magic concedes and says
it's michael's league right
michael plays he's crushing everybody
kobe shows up
michael says i respect this guy kobe
wins three championships right
michael says it's not kobe's league
right kobe then lebron okay meaning it's
not easy to give it to the next guy
michael's had a hard time giving it to
lebron he gives him credit but he
doesn't say this guys do you think
trump's a guy that's going to do that so
here's the other part i go here's the
other part i go with this okay you're
not thinking he does that i i don't
think i don't think he does okay so then
let me ask the follow-up question wait
wait but what you're describing in one
word i would hope he does but
what you're asking us in one word is
does trump have it in him to be humble
or have humility have humility
you're describing humility that's what
you're describing because you're talking
about these great legends of basketball
who said
with all humility i hand over i don't
think anybody hang over
yeah
the difference is
physical limitations start to wane when
you're in your mid-30s right yeah so you
know jordan had just beaten matt just
beaten magic yeah jordan had just
retired now he's back with the wizards
physically they couldn't keep up yeah
trump could keep going like
he could keep up physically he can get
up there and talk for hours so let's let
me ask the other question let me ask you
another question for you here's the
other question for you you know how
sometimes you
uh uh you know you think you need like
for example somebody said well patrick
why'd you say that to arnold
you know that's the interview you want
to do it's not if arnold wants to come
on great if he doesn't he doesn't
freedom is way important to me than me
interviewing arnold it's not like oh my
gosh he's never gonna interview i'm
totally okay with that i support freedom
you said screw your freedom i support
freedom that's where i'm at right okay
do you think
desantis needs mega to win
yes okay so now that's the second
problem so no so i don't disagree with
you okay so i think he does but here's
the other part take mega okay in mega's
mind who do you think is going to win in
2024 i think magga has i'm not even
being facetious yeah has pledged their
loyalty to donald j fair that's fine i
don't this i don't dispute that they
think 2020 he won right and now they
still think he won exactly so so um this
is not like we're not convincing each
other so 2020 the they're certain
trump's going to run and trump's going
to win is what they think
and mega would prefer to have trump over
the sanctions it's not even close but
here's my question and this is the part
where i where i i see slightly different
than than you do and this is this is
where i see slightly different than you
do
i think is there a dramatic difference
between sanders and hillary
yeah dramatic yes or no pretty dramatic
is there a dramatic difference between
sanders and uh uh and biden well sanders
and anyone is dramatic yeah
very very very very dramatic right okay
you know is there a dramatic difference
between uh you know a mccain and a who
did mccain who did mccain take out
mccain took out who was it romney jeb
bush at the time jeb bush okay is there
a dramatic difference between mccain and
jeb bush no no okay is there a dramatic
difference between uh
romney and jeb bush
very very subtle but basically no is
there is there a dramatic difference in
policies between desantis and trump
not dramatic that's why i think mega
will support
i think mega will support
i think mega will support it
if what no i think magazine if desantis
becomes the nominee i think magazine if
trump is in the picture desantis is not
going to be the nominee if republicans
if the 78 million
people who voted republicans a lot of
people other choices you humbly disagree
with how many the billionaires no no
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question
do you think do you think private equity
and hedge fund hedge fund people give
you money before having a meeting with
you
more often times no no hell no
do you not think the meetings already
been had with desantis that nobody knows
because you know what question they're
asking
do you nothing those guys with the money
you you think they sit there and you
know we got something on valuetainment
investment groups somebody else said tom
and i are at the house like midnight one
guy sends the money they want money from
us he says hey my idea is i'm running a
mortgage company i want 200 000 to help
me in my business here's my routing
number account number please send me two
hundred thousand dollars oh yeah yeah of
course send them the money right now
okay it's in the mail
it was the twitter business plan 140
characters do you think money people
just sit there and say yeah
they didn't say they didn't
differentiate whether he's running for
governor or for president though no no
no he's definitely running for governor
no no i'm sorry no it's trump against
desantis money because trump against
that that was to compare palou in black
money black desentis
they're not saying this without having
had the conversation so the conversation
you're gonna have with the santas
knowing how desantis is do you think he
said he's running 2024
do you think i don't think he's
guaranteed anything i think i agree with
you but do you think desantis knows how
to speak sign language like you know
what i'm saying
do you think desantis knows how to say
that like the the this you know what do
you say when you say hey uh the season's
over peyton are you gonna be retiring
what's this famous speech well you know
i'm gonna go spend some time with the
family and figure out what we're going
to do and then probably within the next
few weeks after the dust is settled
we're probably going to make a decision
and see what we're going to do with
retirement right that whole [ __ ]
speech that everybody has memorized you
and i can do it we don't even play in
the nfl right so they asked the santas
they santas are you running for office
he's going to say
well uh uh i'm very happy right now
being the governor of florida we're
doing a great job we still have a lot of
work to do i'm here to help the people
that's right i'm very happy with what
we're doing we've still got something
he's written in the script yeah he and
he knows but he says but if america
needs me i would certainly consider you
know what i'm saying like that's so to
me money guys are sitting there saying
yep and i think mega would love because
listen
40 years from now you're going to be 80.
jesus okay
i'll be running against chuck grassley
he'll still be freaking out i'm sorry
but can you can we can we have a moment
of silence so that adam can accumulate
that thought
it's like the kevin hart when he sat
against that what's that the actor he
says i'm 56 year old damn you know
don cheadle hillary yes right he says
damn but 40 years from now you're 80.
okay
well here's what's gonna happen he's
still in shock do you do you not do you
not think we're gonna sit there and your
kids
10 20 year olds are going to ask
questions they're going to say
man
how was this trump guy
and you're going to have
a hundred stories per one story for
biden
because what we're experiencing right
now is going to be written about a
thousand years from now appreciate the
fact that we had a president donald j
trump because there's never been a
person more entertaining i don't know
why you need to say appreciate
you you have to though that's like
saying i really like krusty the clown
from the simpsons he's got crazy stories
big difference but it doesn't like i
want him to be my president there's a
big difference between krusty the clown
and a guy that made it in business he
won in tv women party you know
shadow of his father he wants to be a
reality star kids are winning his kids
are doing good in their lives he is one
at the highest level no matter how much
[ __ ] everybody talks i'm not here
supporting the guy i'm supporting the
man that has won even though he had so
much criticism against him for 40 50
years and back in the 80s he told oprah
if americans i would run and i would win
because i'm a winner and he won he read
that and obama said you're never going
to be a president and he proved them
wrong at a dinner hundred thousand
dollar dinner table there and obama
talks [ __ ] about him but he's not a glue
guy but it's not i didn't say he's a
glue guy what i'm telling you is you're
gonna appreciate the fact that you
watched the last four or five years this
you will talk about whether you like him
or not it's gonna happen right it's like
talking about churchill when he was
hated but fast forward how many years
later everybody's writing about the guy
and how many books have been written
about this guy this is where i'm going
with this
do you think he
can be the nominee who
trump if desantis and him run can trump
be the nominee can republican
can republicans get behind trump what of
course do you think republicans can get
behind trump no i think the moderate
middle i think that moderate 10 percent
has been lost where are you at yeah i i
i have to agree kai what are you
thinking from your standpoint as a 22
year old going on 75 what do you think
about this 88 i'm sorry time flies time
flies uh no i think that with even for
desantis even without trump's official
like um
endorsement i think that he could pull
away a large chunk of the
maggot crowd just because his policies
and his personality is less kind of on
the extreme on that end so i think
there's a large part of people even
possibly like people like adam where
they're
disgust for him they won't vote just
because of that but based off of
policies they're more willing to like
lean that way so i think
he could even draw more votes from the
left as well in terms of his reasonable
approach he's already said if desantis
runs he would vote for him yeah so i
would vote for desantis over biden
i would i would vote i wouldn't vote for
donald trump again we've already seen
what he's done for the four years he
doesn't bring the country together he's
crushing it
i'm not even saying fighting is that
good guidance like the goat i'm not even
saying
it's it's it's not a binary option it
isn't it is a binary option at that
point you know it's not about you could
do a joe rogan and vote for joe
jorgensen and waste but you're not
there's no importance
danielle hit the nail on the head we
need somebody young vibrant who can get
this it's nice
together that's not the that's not the
talk but that is no it's not i know it's
no it's
i asked the question for you sweetheart
i said if
if i said if can trump win as a nominee
you set up for can you win the
republican yeah
then i said if your choice is republican
biden you said what you're still gonna
go biden if what if it's trump and biden
you're going to go by i don't want trump
again okay i just don't want him so so
let's move on let's get at the center
but let's get out marco rubio we're not
hearing the question here let me ask the
question one more time i have the same
answer i don't want trump so who would
you vote for biden again joe jorgensen
so you wouldn't vote for him you don't
want trump and either does 60 of the
country your answer is a good answer yes
so you're saying you're not going to do
biden or trump you're going to go
somebody else yes okay fine that's fine
that's not a problem so for you what
you're saying is my vote's not going to
count i don't give a [ __ ] my vote counts
i'll be relevant
and i'm just going to go without biden
or without you you talked about this
with rogan we're like i know you were
kind of being facetious you're like yo
and rogan that one of the greatest uh
presidents ever he got 80 million votes
more and he even said look they were not
voting for biden they were voting
against trump and that's
a problem for trump
and
it's
someone like a desantis i am someone
like a descendant would get people to
vote i'm logical enough to know i'm
logical enough to know where you can set
aside the emotions and know
if there is no co anybody that was
president take any president of the last
45 of them clinton give them covet do
they get reelected
give them any president we've ever had
given cover do they get reelected likely
not okay then this is not a trump thing
now let me ask you this take cover does
trump get reelected
likely yes likely yes so this isn't
about the fact that people didn't want
trump yeah no you're like saying pretend
covenant no no no no
no but this is not the point though
we're talking logic here people voted
against them because they wanted to see
somebody else handle covet differently
not because they didn't want trump
there's these are two different
arguments here correct so these are two
different arguments they also think he
handled coveted poorly that's okay no
we're not trying to tell you we're gonna
push back because he was not fiscally
conservative he wasn't yeah but american
people american people didn't want a ted
cruz you're right i i get it but what
i'm saying is it wasn't
what i'm saying is for a lot of very
conservative people
covet did not play into their decision
as to whether they did or did not want
to re-elect trump that's all i'm saying
there were other factors at play but
that's not yeah you're talking i mean
this is the guy who created operation
warp speed
set the standard for the entire world
yeah but he also had the audacity to go
against the number one enemy while all
the presidents last 20 years i've been
[ __ ] bricks going up against china
and they allowed them to get stronger so
this is not a republican democratic
thing i'm sorry we're sitting here right
now and china's you know pushing
everybody around you know they're
charging sixteen thousand dollars per
container that was two thousand dollars
a year ago that's coming here from
shanghai and fedex
40. it was 2 000 last year 40 000. it
was two last year now 40. so fedex
you know nike all of these guys are
coming out saying we have to raise
prices yeah you think that's going to
happen under trump when he faced off
against him you think trump would say
charge 40 000 against see what i do to
you what is biden don't biden say ah
keep it at 40. keep it at 16. i'm sorry
so if our number one enemy is china and
the president is not willing to go up
against him no no no so i'm i'm not
sitting here
this is not a throwing of trump under
the bus situation here disagreeing
you're going to be shocked to trump's
credit biden has upheld everything trump
has been doing with china he's basically
saying you were handling it right
okay are you serious about that comment
you just made yeah really you're serious
about the comment you just made what's
going on with the border right now
what's going on with the board i said
china no no china china's one
no no i said china no stop stop stop
let me ask you this question here two
thousand a year and a half ago container
sixteen thousand she says forty i'm
gonna stick to 16 000. that's eight
times one hang on no hang on a second
bro what do you mean that's one thing
sixteen thousand go to a rolex shop they
have one rolex for sale how come we
don't have rolexes they're making them
go to go to cars right now how much
prices are up right now go what's going
on with cars today try finding chip
shortages what the hell is going on with
chip shortages what is going on with
chip shortages why because we're rolling
do you think that just happens
we're relying on a country called china
he would put his foot down biden's not
putting his foot down with china what
has biden done differently on china what
has he done differently i just told you
two to sixteen thousand but the chip
shortage pat was been going on for two
years now
trump would have done something about
that he had the opportunity to and he
interviewed danielle and he said
something to the fact that
trump was focusing on soybeans rather
than semiconductors did you not i i said
exactly that and right now but but to
patrick's point
biden's not incrementally doing this
while china is conducting economic
warfare against the united states so
for me for me for me here's where i'm
going with this
to say american people didn't want trump
because they didn't want trump as a
bunch of crock of [ __ ] okay
52 percent wanted this guy okay
so so no no he got he won and he bit
hillary and hillary was like the
president was saying in 16. bro what are
you talking about people wanted this guy
and every 16. everything he said he did
everything he did he is he said he did
everything taxes went lower economy went
higher unemployment blacks hispanics
latino women everything would every
crime
isis went lower not seven trillion it
went up because of his last 12 months
you keep saying something like that but
how much did it go up under trump
it was the last 12 months under covet
when he did stimulus yes it did go but
because they had no choice out there
there was only a couple trillion at that
point no
give me some numbers daniel no i still
and and again this is where i push back
you only get to train americans to not
want to work one time
and that six hundred dollars extra a
week i understand that we were in the
middle of a crisis but it didn't have to
be six hundred well first of all daniel
first of all are you kidding me with
these comments you guys are making you
guys are smarter than me here both of
you guys no are you kidding me with
these comments you guys are making what
no let me let me push back a little bit
right let me push back a little bit what
are we talking about we're talking about
somebody signing socialism into law in
the united states what was his choice
though tell me what he does he could
have said tell me what he's excessive
what does he do when california tells
people you can't go to work what are we
doing what do i do if i'm sitting in
california newsome is a bla all these
guys are saying you can't do [ __ ] what
does he do
new york says he almost says too much
cuomo says i need more hospital beds the
guy brings a freaking ship everything we
went through he was doing this is a
black swan so you're gonna put a black
swan on a guy that we've never
experienced about talking about that i'm
saying prior to saying we paid workers
too much to not work
a true republican would have pushed back
and said i don't think that's excessive
that is a bernie sanders level of
stimulus that we're injecting into the
economy it's excessive you cannot do
that yes you can no you cannot do that
let me explain to you why you cannot do
that now people don't want to go back to
work all they needed was that time off
let me let me ask you a question
what comes first
what comes first the entrepreneur or the
employee what comes first the
entrepreneur okay so let me ask you this
what came first the stimulus or the
protesting or covet or the division what
came first
what came first code came first okay
then what do you want me to do division
then
and what do you want the guy to do
and then to top everything off
since you're speaking since you're
bringing up the subject of entrepreneurs
the cares act slaughtered small
businesses in america
slaughtered them when the cares act when
uh
what's the alternative the alternative
would have been something on a smaller
scale okay oh who's gonna vote for that
say he does the alternative then what
happened he's he's the executive he's
got veto power then what happens then he
says he she says to the democrats and
the republicans go legislation about how
this works
that's not how this works for freaking
know that if you decide a or b no matter
what you decide they're going to [ __ ] on
you and they did again no matter what
this guy decided we're sitting here
saying that three and a half trillion
dollars it's exhausting
do that i'm on camera on podcasts saying
i don't support free money when andrew
yang was running talking ubi i i went on
the hill they went after me for me not
supporting andrew young's ubi i don't
support any of that i'm not sitting here
supporting anything i don't either i'm
not the one who signed it into law i'm
not the one who signed paying americans
what else could he have done twenty five
hundred dollars a month obsessive give
me 45 president 44 presidents before him
if they were in the same situation as
kova does do they get reelected
paying people
yes they could have again but you're
you're asking the question about
fiscally conservative republicans
because the issue he was not one of them
they're unpopular
there's only one area where i'm going to
go where i'm going to be on your side
here's only one area where i'm going to
go
here's where the only side i'm going to
go where i'm going to be on that side
he created unnecessary enemies
he created unnecessary enemies i don't
know a president of my lifetime that
created unnecessary enemies sun tzu says
when the enemy is asleep don't wake his
ass up
what the hell are you doing waking
people up what is the matter with you
and he did that for four years why are
you waking unnecessary enemies up he did
that that's why he didn't get re-elected
he didn't get re-elected because his
policies weren't effective he got
re-elected because he's saying you're a
[ __ ] you're an idiot you're in this you
don't convert people calling them morons
for four years now to his defense to his
defense
what channel supported him what
newspaper supported him what magazine
supported him who supported him what
mainstream who supported this guy
nothing
it was game game game game game and the
moment they realized the russia thing
was a dossier from hillary everybody
would sign oh no no don't even talk
about it so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]